I mean congratulations
yeah what are you thinking to success of
this song babe
it just really blows my mind every day
like when I write music or when I'm like
rapping I'm not really thinking oh my
gosh is gonna go crazy like I'm just
making it cuz I like it and I know my
hotties are gonna like it but just for
it to have blowing up the way it did I
was like oh my gosh this is so crazy and
then for me to have the Beyonce do you
just like text I know you're a wrap
you're represented by rock nation which
is jay-z's company so I know there's an
end to you Texas J and you're like oh I
need Beyonce just Beyonce hear the song
of Texas you I want to get on it I'll
know that I'm you know represented by
rock formation but it's like a little
family over there so somebody from my
team he was like Beyonce but literally
on the sky became like not like and so
you have you like FaceTime with each
other have you set her like queen bee a
flower arrangement congratulations are
songs of the rate just went up honey the
razor show me the rain
I also think this is an amazing moment
in music for for women and oh my gosh
because here you are battling you and
Beyonce are battling out on the charts
against Jota cat and Nicki Minaj who was
a collaborator on your last hit song so
like have you spoken to Nicki are you
like girl look at us we are over social
media and like she was just saying like
she's just so proud to be a part of my
history day you know happened so I mean
like that's just crazy like for women
topping the charts when was the last
time now do you know the savage
challenge like have you are you into it
no I know how to do all the challenges
do you know the savage challenge no
y'all watch me I don't know how to dance
them I'm not that coordinated like I
can't even exercise so I listen all
right I know the words and I love I
watched all the videos you know I see
everybody doing it but I haven't I
haven't mustered up the courage to
actually try to do it when I would man I
forgot to do it what I would make it
alright just watch just give a punch
like just a punch it's all you need to
do know this one I don't have to sway to
hips
so first of all I want to know from both
of you how did you get involved in the
show I'll let Megan go first
Chris might actually they came to me he
was like what do you think about joining
legendary
it's gonna be a show about ballroom he
basically explained to me what it was I
like looked up everything I knew about
ballroom on YouTube and I'm like I want
to do this it would be a really cool
thing and like really it was
inspirational to me because I see
everybody performing it going so hard
like they may be one of be better
performer so I really wanted to be a
part of the world I really understanding
what ballroom is I love that lot
I actually I became a part of me from
jameelah from Jameela Jamil um you know
as you know I'm her two stylist and she
was like I don't you know I'm I'm
participated in this show it's gonna be
really really fabulous I would love for
you to do my wardrobe and I was like
what sort of bow and she was like this
about ballroom I'm like lay the ballroom
faro and she like right exactly so she
was like yeah and so I was like come on
you know I'll dress you I'll be happy to
do it I just to be on set and be around
you know the kids the kids will be great
and so they're all the same I got a call
from my agent it was like oh they want
you to be a judge on legendary I was
like where did that come from but I'm in
so yeah it all came to me from Jamila
which I'm really grateful grateful to
her for because it was an amazing
experience
yeah LA I wanted to ask you um you are
very familiar with ballroom can you
explain it in a simple term to our
viewers who might not know what you mean
when you say the ballroom oh I don't
know I can explain it I found you as
simple as possible so the ballroom is
it's all subculture right of the black
and brown gay community started in New
York years and years and years ago and
it's it's like the world's greatest
count let's all look for a lot of super
talented people that have haven't had
the chance to be introduced or
represented in the mainstream and the
fashion on the show you get very
judgmental my fat well you know be
really really honest but it's all I love
and that's the way I show my love
they're tough you know I mean he did but
that's what we love about him you know
and Megan you're the lover and I wasn't
expecting mrs. Savage to be the one that
misses friendships this is your everyone
gets a trophy people who were involved
in ballroom but I really I had never
been to a bar and I really didn't do my
homework on didn't know what it was so
when I did my homework and then being a
part of his hand is live in my face I
was just really excited the whole time
like it was something new to me I didn't
have anything bad to say because I can't
be too harsh about something I don't
have just so much expertise oh but by
the end of the show like I knew what I
was looking for I knew what I was
looking at and I still wish I could have
let everybody all right oh it was so
beautiful to watch I stayed next to uh
to Megan and you don't like you you come
in you think one thing like this tough
rap girl from you know from Texas and
she is such a beautiful beautiful spirit
and you know even it was hard for her
like she said to make to make those you
know kind of tough calls and and harsh
decisions because she I'm so happy that
America will get to see how beautiful of
a person Megan is like I fell in love
with Meg like I feel like she's so free
I guess
question is people but Bo gang had
existed already and if you watch the
last season oppose you know all about
history of this that's how I learnt my
history and Madonna sort of brought it
to the mainstream kind of took that and
like put it forward do you think there's
any chance that you would ever guest
star on this show because cross yeah
fingers crossed
absolutely oh I hope so I think I think
there's gonna be a lot of interest I
think he's gonna you know I could only
use RuPaul's Drag Race is kind of like a
comparison but you know the the star
power and the guest judges just got
bigger and bigger
after more people became a fan in the
show so I hope I think the show is
really special I think where every judge
brings to the show
they Shawn brings to the show I think
that that people will become fans of the
show and ever want to be on this
including Donna Donna Oh from the the
people who are actually on the shows
like everybody who was a part of it like
this when I say this I was crying half
the time let's say so I'm just so happy
that people are gonna be able to see the
lives of everybody that was gonna show
that how hard they work to to you know
meet Nicole meet the goals beat the next
team like they really went hard and I
just feel like it's gonna inspire other
people to never halfway
[Music]